fresh quest crazy fresh food rest
original store 1917 which i think is an
incredible films knives out I really
loved as well I'm trying to go through
the list the last things I've seen so
many films in the last two weeks untap
Jim I'm hustlers was probably one the
best I love love church I run it for a
while I love obviously my dog dolomite a
lot parasite director bong parasites
amazing parasite you didn't even have to
finish the question I think I went in
thinking it was gonna be an actual
little worm type of parasite so boy was
I surprised I haven't seen no women yet
so I'm dying to see that I want to see a
jojo rabid marriage story I'm very
excited well I don't want to say too
much more other films in case they
people vote for them instead of me
[Music]
I'm really thinking to meet myself our
pocket ball I'm excited just to be here
just be part of this again I'm Abed Brad
Pitt yeah freaking out Pam reese
witherspoon queen be your enemy Tom
Hanks is my celebrity crush I love Tom
Hanks his film Tom Hanks I mean not to
cheer for the home team but what a great
night to be here with Toy Story 4 and
have him up for such an incredible award
I always hear everybody I saw Olivia :
on the carpet I didn't realize she was
back this year but it's cuz of the crowd
Phoebe wall a bridge it's just like
everything everything I'll just pass
Eddie on the carpet
it's mr. Murchison that was pretty dope
you know I'm excited to see all my
classmates because I haven't really seen
anybody and you know this year I'm
excited for Reese and Jen obviously as
nominees both of our leaves are up
against each other together with each
other that's very exciting
so am i excited to see you know I mean
you know what I am really excited about
is sitting down with Adam and Scarlett
and Laura and having all of us it's the
same table together celebrating our
movie I love Nora
aquafina and the farewell and knives out
and Chernobyl and parasite so I'm
excited I don't know I Ellen DeGeneres I
just saw her JLo's approaching the
building I heard whispers of it I'm just
it's everyone's coming tonight and it's
crazy it's
I'm really excited
[Music]
you